was ist gesünder cola oder smudo wenn
ich schon so frage ihr wollt wissen wie
gesund oder ungesund ist fruchtzucker
ich will dass heute am beispiel cola
versus modi durchgehen dass cola und
besonders sollte inzwischen bei jedem
angekommen sein je nach marke enthält
cola zehn bis elf gramm zucker pro 100
milliliter in einer einzigen standort
500 milliliter cola flasche nimmt man
also 50 bis 55 gramm zucker zu und damit
ist dann auch schon der empfohlene
tageswert überschritten außerdem bei
gleichen kalorien macht trinken weniger
satt als smt canaries kann man das
nennen also einfach nur kalorien ohne
brauchbare nährstoffe nicht dass zucker
kein wichtiger nährstoff wäre unser
körper braucht zucker als energiequelle
vor allem unser gehirn läuft auf zucker
aber ein typischer westlicher
lebensstandard versorgt uns mit
ausreichend zucker vor allem über
kohlenhydrate süßigkeiten und softdrinks
sind also reines vergnügen ohne
irgendeine gesundheitliche notwendigkeit
also im gegenteil es ist schlecht
stattdessen lieber 10 dingwerth zu faul
sich selbst was zu mixen kann sich so
was in jedem supermarkt kaufen und
meisten betonen dass hier nur obst drin
ist und kein zusätzlicher zucker aber
wozu auch denn hier ist genau so viel
sogar drin wie in cola wenn manches nur
dies ist ein bisschen weniger zucker
eiweiß ist es tatsächlich genauso viel
wie in cola und bei einigen sogar noch
mehr über 310 gramm pro 100 milliliter
aber der zucker hier drin ist doch kein
haushaltszucker sondern natürlicher
zucker aus obst und früchten oder da bin
ich schon so fragt haushaltszucker heißt
saccharose oder auch so große und ist
ein zweifach zucker bestehend aus
glucose und fructose zur hälfte besteht
haushaltszucker also aus glukose die
bedeutung von glukose für unseren
stoffwechsel hab ich in unserem video zu
low carb erklärt könnt ihr euch da noch
mal anschauen die andere hälfte ist
fruktose auch bekannt als fruchtzucker
der name fruchtzucker kann ihre führend
sein denn früchte und obst enthalten
nicht nur zucker sondern eben auch
fruktose und glucose das verhältnis von
fruktose glukose kann anders ausfallen
als
haushaltszucker große eins zu eins ist
aber prinzipiell essen wir mit obst auch
einfach nur zucker aber ist fruktose
jetzt irgendwie besser oder schlechter
als glukose ja zum großen teil ist es
einfach dasselbe denn wenn wir kurse
essen wird sie in unserem stoffwechsel
zu einem großen teil in die glukose
umgewandelt das heißt puncto sie ist im
endeffekt auch nichts anderes als kurse
zumindest zu einem großen teil und was
passiert mit dem rest der fruktose der
nicht in glukose umgewandelt wird ihr
scheiden sich die geister
man kann es als vorteil sehen dass nicht
die gesamte fruktose in glukose
umgewandelt wird denn klose ist das
molekül das die insulin antwort in
unserem körper triggert und deswegen
auch in der entwicklung von diabetes typ
2 eine rolle spielt allerdings gibt es
eine menge von studien die einen
zusammenhang sehen zwischen einem hohen
fruktose konsum und diabetes typ 2 der
mediziner robert lustig oder plastik wie
sagen die amis der jede art von zucker
als gift bezeichnet geht so weit zu
behaupten dass kurse genau so schädlich
sei wie alkohol denn im gegensatz zur
glukose wird fruktose auch in der leber
verstoffwechselt was zu einer so
genannten on alcohol experten führen
kann also eine alkohol nur durch
fruktose man muss aber dazu sagen dass
lustig oder last ich selbst nicht an
diesen stoffwechsel mechanismen forscht
die menschen die daran tatsächlich
forschen sind da deutlich vorsichtiger
ob und inwieweit struktur so eine
fettleber verursachen kann ist eine
ernst zunehmende sorge ist aber noch
nicht wissenschaftlich geklärt aber
solange wir auf weitere
forschungsergebnisse warten können wir
schon mal zwei sachen mitnehmen erstens
weniger zucker essen ist definitiv eine
gute idee den zucker ist definitiv runde
und zweitens hier ist gleich viel zucker
drin aber wenn hier sowieso katrins
warum wird obst essen dann überhaupt
empfohlen im gegensatz cola besteht obst
nicht aus leeren kalorien wir haben hier
vitamine mineralien vor säure
ballaststoffen bei smoothies ende das
nächste mal im supermarkt sei dann
schaut mal selbst auf die inhaltsstoffe
in der regel bestehen die nicht zu 100
prozent aus voll obst oder voll frucht
sondern enthalte
in fruchtsäfte deswegen trinken sich
dieses möglich ist auch so - weil da
eben keine ballaststoffe keine
cellulosefasern undsoweiter mehr drin
sind natürlich sind dann auch die
vitamine und so weiter drin aber wir
haben bei saft eine deutlich höhere
zucker dichte als wenn ihr dasselbe obst
essen würde
während also sonst muss ich einfach so
runter trinkt würde euch dieselbe menge
obst definitiv satter machen da ihr so
viel zucker auf einmal zurücknehmen kann
dass die positiven effekte der vitamine
negativ kompensieren bis das würde die
reine multivitamin tablette mit cola
trinken aber nicht alles nur wir sind
schlecht smoothies selbst zu machen ist
schon mal deutlich besser also kein saft
pressen sondern das volle obst einfach
nur pürieren so wie es ist mit schale
mit kernen und allem drum und dran so
wie es auch essen würdet und
gegebenfalls mit wasser finden auch
grüne smoothies sind kein verkehrter
trend wenn ihr sie selbst macht und das
grünzeugs reinhaut weil ihr da nicht
ballaststoffe mit rein bringt ohne
zucker und wenn man das richtige rezept
hat dann schmeckt es noch nicht mal so
grün wie man sich das vielleicht
vorstellt deswegen habe ich in der end
card mein lieblings screen smoothie
rezept für euch aber nicht dass gesunde
als obst einfach ganz normal zu essen
erstens je am anfang schon gesagt die
form des essens hat einen einfluss auf
unser sättigung empfinden und zweitens
trinken geht auch schneller als essen
dadurch indem wir dieselben kalorien in
der kürzeren zeit auf einmal zu uns so
dass unser blutzuckerspiegel auch
schneller schlagartiger steigt also
möglichst viel wasser trinken und die
kalorien möglichst über festes essen zu
sich nehmen deswegen jetzt selbst
gemachtes movies zu verteufeln ist auch
zu viel des guten mir persönlich macht
uns nur ihn manchmal einfach mehr spaß
als obst zu essen und kann der
motivation sein an tagen an denen ich
sonst gar kein obst essen würde deswegen
in der end karten green smoothie ihr
rezept für euch wenn ihr noch
themenvorschläge habt schreibt sie immer
gerne in die kommentare
wir sehen uns nächsten donnerstag bis
dahin bleibt sicher so voll dass man ihr
braucht eine reife banane und einen
apfel zitrone oder eine halbe je nachdem
wie sie es gerne mögt und eine handvoll
baby spiel hat wenn ihr anfänger seit
achtet darauf dass es baby spinat ist
normaler spinat isst was für
greens musikfreunde wasser her dem wie
dick oder dünn das gerne hättet in den
mixer und fertig falls ihr das zu hause
ausprobiert ich finde dieses muri ist
absolut instagram übel täglich gerne and
mines inc bin ich auf instagram und
vielen herzlichen dank an alle freunde
oder sonne die uns unterstützt haben
beim publikumsvoting für den grimme
online award morgen also wenn dieses
video rauskommt dann morgen ist die
preisverleihung link zum livestream der
preisverleihung den gibt es in der video
beschreibung drückt uns die daumen